eyes et alan nous nous commente michigan
colorado state il ya combien c'est à
dire 28-18 pour colorado state 24
minutes de la fin c'est pas beau comme
toute l'année à xi'an c'est pas beau
julien donc julien allano julien
spécialiste de la west coast g envergure
toi tu connais bien colorado state est
ce que pour les gens qui connaissent pas
du tout tu peux en parler a vite fait
pour
donner une idée de quel genre d'équipé
16,6 ça veut dire qu'ils ont fait une
bonne saison
ils ont fait une grosse
pub qui
depuis trois ans
autour de
10 et stephen moyer qui commence à voir
maintenant dans
afte et petit le monorail stevens le
mend a créé un tier 1 qui grand ans et
voilà pour l'essentiel sur ces deux
joueurs mais un vrai que d'équipements
et voilà ils ont grandir poule
l'année dernière on fait le nit un march
madness la diva première fois
ils ont saison à prix avait une grosse
voix pectoraux d'investir les quatre
hits qui se battait pour la première
place
que moi belle saison tu arrives en
pleine bourre marche mais m
moi je suis fan depuis 2-3 au
pardon classique le mieux et david roady
et comment tu projettes en nba ce que
quel poste il va jouer
quel genre de joueur
c'est un peu la star de ce match avec
stevens tu disais mercredi et plus sur
les tablettes nba quoi
alors qui va se diriger vers l'europe sa
taille est essentiellement un roadie
sera-t-il un il fait un intérieur qui
femmes à 96 cents plus de 110
pendant deux maîtresses bien sûr
il a développé trois points
il est assez le fort voilà on s'est
parlé j'ai pas les minutes
cercles il en
est
un
et elle est super année c'est qu'il a
vraiment je sais pas compter pour elle
songe
mais du 3 qui servent
3 3 en match à bec et % voient donc
assez correcte
des shoots et 174e soute mais voilà
après paris maintenant attribuée à de
déchets par
le shoot après pour rôle
ils sont ce que tu sais
pas comment dire j'ai essayé d'imaginer
que
j'ai pas retrouvé son autre peut-être
parce que mais c'est un peu la limite il
ay les plus extrêmes et puis en 2010
sont dans un pitch est au coeur
des vi nations
ouais ouais ouais c'est ces gens
regroupe un
bon on a perdu julien salingue est un
petit peu alan tu peux ajouter des
choses sur elle david road i way de
franchement laid si on regarde
statistiquement franck sein d une forte
du championnat cette année
peu de déchet comme à tout ce que dit
julien progression d'année en année peu
de déchets je pense projetable
facilement nba parce que connaîtra son
rôle et fait des choses bien mais peu
d'erreurs surtout je sais pas s'il va la
draf je pense qu'il va y aller puisqu'il
ya une bonne une bonne cote mais les
juniors il pourrait peut-être revenir
une dernière année mais
voilà il saura plus d'ici fin du premier
fin du premier quart temps mais a pas
que lui dans l'équipe parce que moi
j'aime bien aussi leurs shooteurs
spécialistes l'a dit chômage est aussi
un junior vaudois sérieux comme l'a dit
qu'on va vraiment bien dit julien
équiper les construite depuis trois ans
elle est âgée qui connaissent ils savent
jouer ensemble et la montagne noire et
ce n'est pas que
l'antichambre de la pac toile via des
très bonnes équipes dedans il ya des
mêmes des prospects vié qui sortent
chaque année malakite flynn né mias
keita et ou d'ong et ouais ouais
effectivement
bienvenue à ceux qui sont dans le chatt
hésitez pas à envoyer vos questions on
n'a mis que c'était une grande foire aux
questions donc si vous avez des
questions sur les équipes sur les
joueurs de cette march madness n'hésitez
pas donc le mal le premier match vient
de vient de commencer il y à il ya un an
ils en sont où à la mi temps je suis
quasiment perdu quasiment à la cnam
usant colorado state donc mène face au
michigan de moussa diabaté
voilà on espère pour moussa que qu'il va
réussir à passer ce premier tour mais
c'est mal embarqué ah ça y est
il est là celui-ci
le vif le michel houellebecq du sport
ça là je n'avais pas encore eu droit
wes je dis ça pour le nombre de ventes
est pas pour le côté polémique
quand ça va les gars ça va et toi
eh ben ça va au top suis en train de
voir colorado state atomisé michigan
dont je suis heureux as tu t'es plus le
west coast oie à bec orange fait mes
études j'ai fait mes études dans le
colorado mois à je sais pas j'étais un
ordre colorado à la fac donc j'ai été
sur le campus de colorado state a
quelquefois hockey
rémy c'est quoi le match
donc un match par jour on rappelle sur
sur dean là pendant cette march madness
c'est quoi le match 2 donc en vo la nuit
et le matin c'est toi qui commente avec
single tonnes exactement alors il y aura
il y aura toute la team de commentateurs
une vie extra parce que parce que j'ai
d'autres j'ai aussi le snl de trucs
assuré et tout mais la plupart du temps
ce sera chris et moi en effet ce matin
c'était à dio et jacques tout à l'heure
c'est cool parce que le match il est tôt
il à 21h30 ce sera quand même en vo on
vous propose le market north carolina à
tout à l'heure
parce que en fait sur ce premier tour
1er 2e tour surtout je pense je sais pas
ce que c'est moi qui ai programme et je
vais essayer de choisir des des
potentiels match à l'aube 7 ou en tout
cas là où ça peut jouer je vais pas vous
faire des matchs un 16 sur le premier
tour est-ce donc un market north
carolina tout à l'heure qui s'annonce
bien sympa et alors à temps j'essaie de
retrouver le match que je vous est
programmé pour demain c'est le virginia
tech texas que je vous propose de voir
oui bien sûr on en parlait dans la vidéo
de présentation qui est sorti à deux
jours virginia tech il a gagné le
tournoi de conférence est ici si et donc
qui normalement sur la lancée les
équipes comme ça elle peut faire des
aides directes surtout que texas est pas
non plus la panacée
alan tu me contredira pas là dessus et
je crois qu'il ya eu ce qui arrive et
quand ils remplacent les textes actuels
vont taper unis vont taper texas
j'en ai besoin pour mon bracket mais je
pense qu'il faut taper texas texas a
perdu au premier tour du tournoi big toe
l équipe est pas au top c'est que la
première année du projet que le nouveau
coach et le coche de virginia tech est
un des tout meilleurs coach de nice et
donc je pense qu'il va pouvoir
mieux shooter inter qu à tour que je te
préviens déjà il faut suivre ce petit
shooter blanc de moins d'un mètre 85 qui
tire comme un malade mental et c'est pas
mon truc
ça va
ouais c'est que j'arrive boom
texas qui se tenait
et drivé par alors un nouveau coach et
chris byrd qui a rejoint l'ennemi qui
avant était chez texas tech une équipe
faite de toutes pièces avec des
transferts c'est vraiment on appris la
foire un petit peu à tout ce qu'ils
voulaient bien transférer on les a pris
donc on a ramené marcus carte qui venait
de de minnesota on a ramené fine michele
on a ramené à j'oubliais et là forcément
le nom du mend tout à mettre 80 signé à
la new team i allen merci voilà on a mis
tous ces mecs là et
l'exécrable des vinasses ku de kentucky
cette année et on a essayé de faire au
mieux mais c'est une équipe qui n'y a
pas trouvé d'éditeur
qui a gagné en façon très homogène et
qui a pas d'une façon très homogène t'as
pas un vrai fond de jeu donc moi je
pense qu'ils peuvent très vite se faire
sortir malgré malgré beaucoup de groen
effectivement et en plus c'est pas
cadeau comme renminbi n'est
d'entrée de jeu virginia tech on n'est
pas non plus sur quelque chose de facile
à passer pour pour texas donc et les
équipes de l'habituel vont en général
vont avoir un parent quoi c'est
compliqué
c'est pas ta faute tu
en manges je te connais je profite conte
et julien et après on revient à toi rémy
pour pour parler un petit peu de ton
bracket pour voir
j'en ai fait un jour on en a fait un
petit show les jo avec vous aussi des
gars mais on en a fait un petit interne
à ok julien en fait il ya plein
d'équipés de l'ouest qui sont
intéressantes et qu'on connaît pas trop
j'aimerais qu'ils me parlent alors
attendez je vais vous mettre le
programme si j'y arrive
je vais vous mettre le programme
boum boum
normalement vous voyez
quel
oui a tancé les grands moyens c'est
canal binz portent
sur
julien qui est ce qu'on à ton côté qui
joue aujourd'hui on à san francisco
notamment il ya san diego state et
hyacinthe maryse surtout à la c'est de
ça que je voulais parler
ces cinq maris qui joue donc à française
une heure une heure vingt
il
ya la bauxite est aussi contre mais avec
toujours est absolument au système on va
peut-être commencer
parce que le match commence dans une
heure et demie après donc face à memphis
le même fils jaden rayne
donc c'est ce match là il montre avec
m'assurer le même fils de jah laine du
rennes 2 et money bay ce qui est revenu
il me semble donc le luxe brikk est
attendu pour la draft l'année prochaine
boyzie state qu'est ce que ça donne
pourquoi ils sont favoris face à memphis
qui une équipe qui est beaucoup plus
médiatisé c'est une équipe qui paraît
qu'en culture depuis longtemps qui se
connaît bien
je vais en vétéran 2 2 à nice il est
notamment
alors est-ce que j'ai manqué emmanuel la
cote qui a un arrière zoom honneur
et
qui à l'intérieur qu'il a je pense
des formes grande partie sur sur dur n
je pense ça même si durant à quelques
centimètres et voilà sinon c'est un jeu
d'équipé raid commettre comme avec farid
cdc des équipes qui jouent
avec un gros collectif il n'y a pas
vraiment de stars
moi j'ai comme ça il n'y a pas vraiment
car là la balle bouge bien il ya alors
ça peut jouer en leur faveur et wade
falloir penser à
si un des joueurs qui est dans le
trouble d autres qui vont tenir le jeu
là dernièrement il ya le freshman degen
hearts compte alors j'ai envoyé
plusieurs fois sa photo sur twitter
parce qu'il a une belle à il a une belle
shy'm dur tu n'as même
il ya un qui à l'intérieur assez costaud
mais je pense qu'il faut garder un oeil
sur lui pour l'année prochaine
ils sont à trois points il est costaud
il n'est pas vraiment très rapide sans
être lancée 1,4 et il est totalement
longue
haleine il a rayé le nom apparemment
déjà pour
la rayer les noms mais en tout cas une
équipe très intéressante et complète a
boy state c'est pas gagné pour memphis
même si je trouve qui c'est une équipe
de memphis qui est un peu
undersea 12h10 large sous classe et on
va dire pour en français donc puisqu'il
son numéro 9 mais il faut une bonne fin
de saison
et jaden du renne montrant presse monte
en pression et c'est
donc c'est pas mal
rémy dit moi je vais je vais partager
maintenant
l'onglet du bracket alors ça c'est mon
bracket donc voilà vous pouvez vous
moquez de moi j'ai mis double champion
ou l'or
aux hommes c'est surprenant
des familles notre-dame et j'ai mis du
coeur champions et d'un t-shirt gonzaga
tu vois
c'est vraiment
absolument on fait de la politique
rémy kaki qui tue à me sortir de ta
région ouest parce que vous avez vous
avez suivi plus que d'habitude la lan c
est cette année quand même sur bin vous
il y avait des matches régulièrement et
c'est donc j'imagine que tu avais déjà
des idées peut-être un peu plus précise
que les années d'avant peut-être que tu
regardais aussi les années d'avant mais
avec respect évident non non tu as
raison
c'était un timbre équipes d'ailleurs
cette année de pouvoir m'impliquer un
petit peu le problème chez moi j'ai
toujours dit ce qu ils tous les baskets
et je kiffe le basket universitaire
notamment moi je me souviens quand
j'étais tout gamin sur sport + quand je
regardais le ciel et de jérôme moïso et
de watson sabran des oufs à l'époque et
donc tu as la ligne et ça m'a toujours
fait rêver il ya toujours eu ce côté
hyper glamour je trouvais donc ça c'est
une ligue que j'avais pas délaissé mais
que j'avais un petit peu moins suivi
parce qu on est tellement pris dans le
tourbillon de la cétoine gay xtrac bas
que forcément tu as moins de temps et
pour sacrer tu vois et donc le fait de
devoir bosser dessus ça m'a fait du bien
de me remettre dans une vraie saison il
sied après je suis moi je reste moins
experts que vous touchez ici mais alors
je suis emmerdé là je voulais ressortir
mon bracket chez pas toi le tir il
marche apparemment mais sur une espionne
là le mien ça bug donc j'ai l'impression
qu'il va avoir trop de connections ce
moment je pense qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
doivent être dessus et donc moi ça ça
bug mais c'est pas grave je me souviens
à peu près tout ce que j'avais pas tous
les pics mais ce que j'avais écrit alors
dans la région ouest j'ai tenté un petit
obsède pas comme toi j'ai fait sortir
duke j'ai dû x ore gonzaga
comme pendant la saison en fait je sais
pas donc
donc j'ai envie de croire à ça pour le
côté c'est peut-être c'est pas c'est pas
réaliste pourtant réaliste ça n'a pas de
sens sportif parce que sportivement je
demande le contrat porte quand même
beaucoup de certitudes mais moi le côté
l'as des aces de coach qui me laisse
croire qu'ils peuvent faire un truc je
te vois arriver avec la narrative en
plus ça arrive souvent la march madness
le la belle histoire se réalise quoi
on se rappelle de virginia qui se fait
sortir dès le premier tour en seed 1
face aux 16 et l'année d'après il
remporte le titre c'était la revanche
comment il s'appelle tombe raquette je
peux essayer de le chercher peut-être
bon jeu s'appellerait si tu arrives à le
retrouver il s'appelle rémy reverchon
deux n'ont pas pourquoi j'ai fait
n'importe quoi mais ça fait frémir
il appelle à un second tour ouais c'est
ça je ne sais pas ce qui était le à moi
je suis l'un des rares films où j'espère
que
providence qui galère un peu contre
south dakota state
moi je crois que j'ai émis l'obs est
aussi tout le monde l'appelait ce fut
notre façon tout le monde
le meneur de sa côte est est laid
jackrabbit il est incroyable avec l'ina
allemande je passe chez mr ben sherman
ou alors juste tous je vous pose une
question vous la prenez à la volée
pendant que je cherche le bracket de
rémy
comment vous vous essayez de sentir les
obsède je sais que moi j'ai une théorie
que je partagerai après mai mais comment
êtes vous essayer de sentir les obsèques
au-delà du fait d'avoir vu ou pas les
équipes est ce qu'il ya un genre
d'équipé vous vous dites tiens ça c'est
une équipe à obsède ça c'est pas une
équipe 7 si elle s'appelle michigan
l'ue27 après derrière
non moi je dirais
pardon pardon hein j'adore surtout
michigan alors déjà d'une feinte tension
parce qu'ils jouent mais colorado state
donc non non il y aura pas de cette
annonce et moi j'étais heureux de ce
tatouage et du colorado street
mais pourtant tu vas me dire que
michigan c'était une équipe à auxerre
non mais tous les ans faisait cette fois
tout d'abord oui d'accord mais parce que
là cette année là pour le coup c'est mal
barré
non enfin moi je suis encore une fois je
suis plus brut que vous là dessus et moi
je me fie vachement et s'étaient
détournés argument la valeur sûre chez
plus qualité d'autres je me suis
vachement à la forme récente c'est à
dire autour de conférences une équipe
c'est sûr qui s'est fait sortir sur son
premier tour de trois conférences même
si elle a fait une belle saison
régulière qui lui donne un site jean
sérien 5 6 7 je vais plutôt avoir
tendance à aller sur l'équipe qui a
qualifié qui avait fini fort sa saison
voit clairement
comment l'argument de la dynamique sur
la fin de saison est aussi l'argument de
l'expérience d'une équipe qui a joué
ensemble depuis deux trois ans pour ça
que j'ai ri chang qui valait l'idate
alors ça serait un gros gros exploit
mais
c'est une équipe qu'il ya trois joueurs
qui ont joué ça fait cinq ans qu'ils
jouent ensemble a rich man pour les
spiders de richmond et donc ils sont
tous revenus de 5e année pour vouloir
voilà aller loin la march madness faire
quelque chose
je pense qu'une équipe qui se connaît
qui a déjà beaucoup de minutes ensemble
et qui a un fort meneur capable de créer
c'est ça ce qui te fait aller loin en
mars
une équipe qui est pas non plus trop
dépendante dans ce domaine de jeu genre
ya des équipes qui vivent beaucoup et
qui meurt beaucoup par le tir extérieur
à la pana et je pense que l'alabama peut
être une équipe qui se fait que c'est un
soir où ça rentre pas et que globalement
ces éliminations directes donc à des
matchs ou battu rentrer dedans et puis
un discours lorsque tu te fais sortir
absolument baugé pas réussi à trouver le
bracket de bien sûr je dis ça mais
également de va se faire exploser par
iowa dans trois heures
mais toi aussi tu portes pathé colonel
cela un peu de condition physique
qui boite et mais bon ouais mais alors
alors ma ma théorie ma théorie sur les
obsède ce qui va évidemment pas se
vérifier c'est que il faut toujours une
sorte de meneur star ou arrière star
dans l'équipe qui va obséder je me
rappelle de thomasz world cup vous
rappelez de thomas soit maintenant il
joue en euroligue il semble
exactement à biline christiane il y à
mouiller exemples comme ça 2 il faut des
arrières fort en fait pour gagner un
march madness il faut des gars qui
avaient provoqué des fautes qui peuvent
prendre feu et derrière avec la défense
collective etc parfois ça va passer mais
du coup je vais je vais du coup remettre
mon mon bracket après on ira voir ceux
de sedan à l'année et hugues mai
mais je vais remettre mon bracket du
coup je crois que j'ai mis par exemple
voilà j'ai pas un cerveau pour faire
deux choses en même temps c'est
pour ça qu'on se marie avec
streit a fait 2 bracket incroyable ouais
j'ai fait j'ai fait mon bracket un peu
ou où il ya des choses qu'ils veulent
que je veux qu'ils arrivent avec ucla
qui va au bout alex haley que je t'aime
de tout mon coeur j'ai sur mon bracket
geminus et les vainqueurs c'est vrai
en vrai c'est pas non plus farfelue
puisque
ils font ils font une bonne saison même
si on attendait mieux et surtout pas
comme disait alan tout à l'heure c'est
l'expérience l'année dernière ils vont
en demi-finale ils sont sortir au buzzer
improbable c'est une équipe qui même
s'ils sont dix points derrière tu peut
jamais être sûr qu'ils vont parvenir à
d'ailleurs julien
m'a dit vas-y vas-y alors émis non alors
moi c'est le coeur qui parle parce que
vous savez que j'ai eu la chance de
vivre là-bas à los angeles et où donc et
voilà à côté de ça cette année là bas je
reviens tout juste là ya trois semaines
j'étais aux états unis je suis allé
faire un reportage sur nico batum là et
les clippers zae des éoliennes avec mon
cadreur renan et xavier vaussion qui est
avec toi ce moment là on a été on a eu
un soir tranquille on a été se faire en
touriste absolue on s'est acheté des
places et tourna et espère un match du
ciel et au poly pavilion c'est quand ils
ont taffé ctek east et arizona state
était sûr mais est hors champ mais mais
pour le coup en plus sur les appeler
comme ça comme c'est moi qui fais la
programmation sur mobinil est pas
impossible que j'aie choisi de faire
deux fois et du ciel et cette saison
du coup d un peu suivie et très
sincèrement si vous me demandez de
parler avec ma tête je crois pas une
seconde que du ciel et sera champion
parce que c'est une équipe qui a été
décrit chaîne de tout au long de l'année
parce que johnny jews and
border line des soit un petit peu je
trouve dans son épanouissement et parce
que je suis fan d'un mec comme
ribéracoise là qu'il ya une énergie
folle mais mais mais qui manque
mon oeil à moi qui manque juste un peu
de talent basket quoi donc je suis si
vous me demandez avec ma tête voilà je
ne vois pas comment lui sied pour être
champion cette année face à des équipes
comme contre saga qui regorge de talent
tu vas mai mais avec le coeur bon ben
voila je me dis que c'est ce côté food
de la march madness et le côté
expérience que tu as mentionné qui fait
que pourquoi pas mais mais c'est plus le
coeur qui parle et dans l'absolu si vous
demandez à un vrai à vide entre
guillemets mais qui suis un peu le
basket j'y crois moyen a eu ses lois
et donc tu m et qui en 27 mois sur des
roulettes cette année bah oui c'est pour
ça aussi que joue cette carte là c'est
qu'il ya pas d'ultra favori sur mon
bracket à moi je te dis j'ai mis du ciel
et parce que c'est le coeur qui parle et
s'ils sont pas champions s'ils sont
champions je m'en voudrais te réponde
pas les arbitres après
bêtement et simplement joue la petite
code c'est à dire que si je parlais
vraiment avec la tête je vous aurais mis
contre sa garde
enfin gonzaga du coup il ya aussi une
narration à faire avec des gars qui
court après depuis des années et
finalement finalement en plus cela ils
ont vraiment ils ont pas un parcours
facile en ils peuvent ils peuvent
prendre soin ball state soi-même fils
dès le deuxième tour ensuite je vais
remonter dans la partie de
sa
qualité de l'arkansas qui peut vraiment
les gêner aussi du col bayard pierre
comme sa soeur de sort de du wine
company yukon
et yukon ils sont un peu surcoté montluc
mais non mais non mais non mais non mais
messieurs non non je trouve que c'est
une équipe très forte parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup de glace est en fait
[Musique]
beaucoup blessé lors
c'est pour samuel etienne que tu as
envie de l'appeler ans parce qu'il ya un
mec qui s'appelle tyson et
suite à
ça marche ces vraies questions pour un
champion et sa 102e que je t'ai 24 à la
suite de
quoi il est il a été beaucoup blessé
hyper fort bulli qui peut jouer en
europe ils ont en colo comme meneur qui
est un vrai bonheur et surtout ils ont
un pivot ultra dominant avec adama
sanogo qui va 28 salles et sur le banc
il ya la petite pépite top 10 l'an
prochain
j'ordonne hawkins qui va arriver
tranquillement sauf au mans qui va tout
casser et qui peut qui peut faire
basculer un match attention du code moi
je les vois passer un comme ça
facilement
ok ça c'est intéressant parce que moi je
crois que je les ai mieux piété
bos les lots bosch
julien on parler de lui si elle est
toute à l'heure puisque c'est une équipe
qui cite quatre mais qui est quand même
candidate de par son histoire et son
vécu un final fort est ce que comme rémy
tu trouves que c'est une équipe qui
plafonne un peu à l'image de zhuhai ne
faisait justement il a fait un bon
tournoi pacte web il finit fort
ouais c'est un gars qui va voir des
séries quoi design donc il faut toujours
se méfier de leader en inde d'ici là il
a pas perdre de son bras ouais sur voilà
certains assis là des plantes et quoi
les gars les maîtres après c'est vrai
que c'est pas une équipe qui a des
talents hors norme comme je m'en tire
mandat correct rémy c'est c'est assez
vous faudra jouer pardon de la pompe à
jouer mais
ouais mais comme tout type de fatima le
coach il a mis deux je trouve qu'il a
mis quand même de l'ordre dans ce que
c'était du cirque c'était là ressemble
pas du tout rémy toi tu les as tu
imagines tu les suivaient quand même vu
que c'est un peu de cantons de coeur
bien sûr
l'arrivée du coach j'ai perdu son nom de
miss chrono microelectronics pas si vous
allez ailleurs
à une extension est ce que je pense que
c'est un contrat à vie
mais celle du 23
octobre qui fait les joueurs qui ramène
sur tout
alors rémy on passe du côté droit du
bracket la partie d'arizona donc le
parti south est sorti chez toi qui vas
au final fort
alors attendu coup je me remets déjà
j'avais mis colorado s'est avancé là
c'était bien
la
gemmi villanova dans cette partie là à
intéressant moi je les hémisphères
obsède par ohio state concerne beaucoup
de monde alors c'est marrant j'ai écouté
il espionne ce matin beaucoup beaucoup
de monde ça divise et beaucoup sur le
plateau on parlait de stade parce qu'il
ya une grosse cote mais alors je suis un
peu à la ramasse là dessus il paraît
qu'il leur manque que monde pour les
débuts du tour voilà de tous qu'on voit
des grands
lidl et la z qui on sait pas s'il est là
et liang le grand blanc s'est passé les
annonces qui s'est quand même un gros
noms qu'on les avait faits nous à
l'époque il est important ouais ouais
sont confiants de cesser leur
wii puis c'est surtout ssh le lieu à
chicago c'est peut-être la meilleure
défense du pays ou pas loin quoi bon
donc c'est pas évident à taper dès le
premier tour mais je me suis dit
justement s'il passe le yoga chicago ça
va sûrement être dur et du coup dans la
dans la foulée villanova ici ils nous
disent ici ont toujours fort à un march
madness mais je suis pas très convaincu
cette année eu que tu as mis obsède
villanova aussi pour quelle raison parce
qu'ils sont petit
gilet d'arrivage bars en fête le
villanova un défaut c'est leur pivot
c'est ixon le pivot il est vraiment très
petit il est assez faible et même s'ils
ont leur super senior avec colleen
gillepsie qui en mission et justin moose
jaw man samuel etc
larnack brendon cette heure que tu m'as
que tu m'as mis des paillettes dans les
yeux pour finalement me décevoir comme
ça mais je trouve qu'ils sont vraiment
petits incendies les dalles qui tu peux
faire un massacre et malacca voilà donc
pour moi ça se joue à l'intérieur est
quand même
intéressant donc rémy tamis villanova
qui bat as qui bat directement arizona
ou arizona se fait sortir avant
je
n'avais pas
arrivée jusqu'à 1
ça c'est intéressant je me demande si
j'avais pas mieux stone qu on a fait
pareil deux fois je crois cette saison
eq single tonnes qui m'avait beaucoup
plus mais qui peut
c'est pareil c'est une équipe des grands
bras pour moi
j'étais au final four l'an dernier
c'est ça si j'avais peur de dire une
bêtise mais je vous ai mis dans mon
bracket josemi houston qui a avancé à
l'élite et qui se faisait sortir par via
nova
l'an dernier avec un coin kg jour des
knicks qui s'intéressent défoncé
comme vous le voyez moi j'ai parié sur
le site de chattanooga
ils ont un joueur nba ils ont un procès
immédiat chat à nous bien et c'est
exactement le genre d'équipé qui fait
l'exception des équipes avec un un
prospect biais d'un collectif à peu près
correct au tour face à une équipe
d'illinois qui avait pas vraiment de
gros joue ainsi ils ont coach tom byrne
qui va écraser du monde dans la raquette
mais
si un beau schéma défensif en face j'ai
pas beaucoup vu jouer chattanooga mai
mais c'est pas non plus une équipe
débile donc maintenant il joue bien et
c'est marrant personne chez vous la
croire arizona
moi je les ai champions abadan voilà
c'est passé le copieur la
regarde et je sais alors pourquoi alors
non intéressant pourquoi vous les avez
champions
mais c'est surtout ils ont le ils ont le
talent plus plus dans bénédicte mathurin
ils ont le niveau de création sur les
extérieurs avec
bénédicte toiture ou kirk ris al
estonian ci revient parce que je l'état
de sa jambe je ne sais pas dans quel
état ils ont le ils ont même tube ellis
de lituaniens que crée aussi ils ont
christian cau locaux en entre défensive
qui est un joueur un des défenseurs les
prises empattement du pays et ils ont un
stoppeur défensif sur les bases
extérieur avec d'haleine terry et ils
ont un français ils sont une communauté
francophone je suis pour eux
beaucoup de noms mais la mito paniers à
trois points dans la finale de
conférence quand le ciel est si l'on
voit là omar balo le malien aussi big
mathurin québécois donc ils ont une
équipe internationale j'apprécie
fortement alors julien avant que avant
que tu t'en ailles parce que je sais que
tu dois y aller arizona c'est aussi ton
c'est aussi ton credo puisque tu es
notre monsieur west coast on le rappelle
chez envergure
arizona pour ceux qui connaissent pas du
tout qu'on pas du tout vu la haine si
cette année c'est une équipe qui a
vraiment passé un cap qui a été
dominante qui mérite son side 1
je pense il faut rendre hommage à un
coude floyd qui dès sa première année en
cours on place un coach assez contesté
on va dire qui mais qu'il y avait
qui avait bien recruter quand même parce
que c'est avec des méthodes contestables
c'est pour ça qu'ils déploient la devise
en disant qu'il avait un kangoo avec un
gros coffre en foutent vraiment qu'ils
avaient des cinq dans le combat et voilà
c'est un gros collectif c'est une
défense rugueuse mcgregor nous allons
parler
et a parlé de l'intéressé moi j'adore ça
vrai sale gosse mais ils sont toujours
quoi la limite de la provocation c'est
une grosse défense physique trois
intérieurs qui tourne qui sont grands et
costauds
et puis voilà sur les lignes extérieures
savaria delà de la création et du shoot
et puis larsson aussi lan qui sort du
banc le meilleur sixième homme de la pac
twelve et qui oscille entre les postes 3
et 4 donc c'est un gros collectif avec
du talent on veut partout et à
l'extérieur l'intérieur
est un bon coach je pense je pense que
c'est un ancien inspecteur de marque
basée à douala alors j'ai laissé passer
la radio ses 20 ans va ça faisait vingt
ans aussi qu'il était un way et qui
était chargé de recruter en europe
notamment c'est lui qui avaient cerné
tous les grands européens devant agde et
qui a emmené un ballo avec lui et ben
laurie joue donc ça fait plaisir
donc moi j'ai pris un bon signe
l'accusé mais champions
ça c'est trop c'est
trop la bonne idée donc ça va pas se
réaliser mais après lui ses invendus
c'est sa conférence normal c'est comme
moi quand je vais donc
le faire ouais je suis étonné que t'es
pas mis bay la règle qui dit d'amis ou
baylor bas je les ai faits gelée pendant
qu'ils se font sortir assez tôt je les
ai vus perdre contre contre contre
contre
autres ue si elle
parce qu ils leur montrent leur meilleur
de joueur donc partir du moment et leur
manque leur meilleur joueur en la
personne de 2 attendue à 3,4 soit ils
peuvent pas ils peuvent pas vous ils
sont trop courts physiquement tu
laissais mes donc voilà j'ai dieu à une
croix sur la raison et je les ai sortis
très bien j'ai juste montrer l'effectif
de
arizona pour si jamais cette équipe va
loin la falloir connaître un petit peu
donc on voit à damas balle le français
le france all in the rye
et puis après ben comme vous l'avez dit
bénédicte mathurin qu'on attend pour
ceux qui connaissent pas à la noce et
loteries quasi assurée pour mâturer ont
vu sa saison
on trouvait qu'il fallut
81,18 comité
c'est pas que ça pourrait tomber jusqu'à
20 matière en
israël pour qu'il écoute si t'écoutes
genre benoît et les huit si tu m'écoutes
moi il est vain voilà
en gros c'est le en gros c'est le
deuxième tiers élargie avec ses joueurs
mais non je pense que l'organisation des
niveaux entre le 8 et le 20 je pensais
bien c'est ça non pas du fait d'être
déférents une énorme différence en fait
cela portera aussi beaucoup de garanties
parce que c'est un joueur sur je pense
il apparaît le plancher le profond le
plus haut mais je sais ce qu'il
apportera 5 mois de juin je pense
qu'israël sera drafté
sandrine sept jours je m'appelle jean
baptiste clément je suis moi je suis
curieux de connaître sa taille réelle
ah ouais tu veux nous faire une ovation
poids qu'il est surcoté non qu'ils aient
le sens qu'il est plus petit que moi si
cette ça me donnait trop trop grand
vraiment alors il fait parce qu'il soit
parce que larsson il est un choix qui
les donner à sis est aussi suite moi je
suis étonné de faim après on verra on
avale compagne attend ça je sais pas si
ça peut le
ça peut être mauvais pour lui si sa
taille décembre parce que toute façon il
aime à sa taille il aura
moi je le vois plus proche d'un mètre 95
autres comme sa médaille d'or à son
sujet je vous dis les plus petites
élèves terrine en moi je trouve qu'il
est plus petit palais en théorie voilà
c'est ça
d'alain terry a à peu près stable à 2 m
me semble on va passer à un
autre parti du bracket
on descend la région de bay lors on en
parlait de psychologie l'abreuver un
schiergen revient toujours pas de put
alors c'est pour ça que je suis pas bien
les cas le match
et produit en semaine de 8 points à la
mi temps face à eauze dakota state
je crois qu'on me demande dans le shaq
ou est ce qu'on regarde les matchs sur
bin sport
c'est ensuite
sur le espn player et en france et je
pense que pour un mois il n'est pas très
très cher j'ai pas j'ai pas l'info mais
je pense que pour un mois il est pas
très cher
et ensuite tu peux te débrouiller mais
n'en citerons pas
cela ne vous regarde pas
donc la partie de baylor je disais avec
donc north carolina market qui est le
match du soir sur bin sport le 8 compte
neuf deux programmes très reconnue donc
selon moi très bon choix de diffusion
même si sainte marie zna j'aurais bien
aimé mais indiana déjà fait une diana ya
deux jours la
mairie en finale de
ces pour renouveler sociale et
renouveler et donc c'est la région avec
kentucky purdue le virginia tech texas
qui sera diffusée demain ah ouais vous
fait vous diffusez que la région est en
fait celle de ucla comme par hasard
et donc la région du ciel est donc rémy
a fait sortir ucla il ya ce soir visait
d'ailleurs les autres vous avez fait
sortir qui de cette région moi je veux
sortir si elle est aussi
je fais sortir du bus est là parce que
cette région là je la trouve dans ce
n'est pas dans sur le terme de qualité
plus plus plus pour moi y'a personne qui
sort vraiment du lot hugues l'a dit baye
la raison sans leur en défensive et
c'est pas la même équipe que l'an
dernier north carolina ils ont que le
nom north carolina pour être
aussi bien côté je les trouve pas bon
très honnêtement je ne les trouve pas
qu'on allait pas très bon
texas pareil c'est un non mais c'est pas
cette année c'est pas extrêmement
impressionnant et y est nous y allons
alors on va se battre entre eux perdu et
kenshi qui j'avais moi je t'ai mis peur
du kent hughes qui a perdu un oeil aussi
aller à l'élite ait pas ce que j'ai de
naïve y est un des tout meilleurs
joueurs de l'as de la saison régulière
des tout meilleurs joueurs du
championnat et je pense qu'il a tout
pour ils ont aussi mis sont aussi bien
construit pour aller loin en mars avec
les grands à l'intérieur que willie
williams il dit avec stefanovich de
shooter main et spécialisés tout ça doc
stefanovich evanovich pareil il va
détruire tellement de gens en dégâts
dramatiques dans deux ans ça va être
incroyable
kentuky
macintosh qui sont peu laissée en fait
tahiti washington il est blessé il n'est
pas il n'est pas bien on voit le niveau
de création sur les extérieurs je fais
pas confiance je pense qu'ils peuvent se
faire taper par me restait tout san
francisco
sera ce serait un gros coup sa voix ses
enfants tandis qu il manque des gens
c'est trop tard le rôle mais il leur
manquait un intérieur c'est ça julien
sapino bel arbre du bélarus ne le
craignait
ah oui c'est à ce non
match facile et la radio anglaise qui
reste aujourd'hui six blessés à
l'entraînement dans les moeurs estate
attention
pourquoi kentucky ne veut jamais mettre
des matchs hors conférence contre murray
state or c'est dans le même état en
novembre décembre parce qu'ils ont
toujours peur de se faire taper c'est
pas à cause du fait qu'ils aient déjà
mort 2
en deux ans mais reste c'est que pour
moi c'est une des meilleures équipes de
mise mais genre cette année
avec deux très bons joueurs à
l'intérieur qui joue très bien ils ont
ils ont failli ils ont ils ont joué
o'byrne à auburn cette année ils seront
vraiment ils les ont embêtés donc on
sait bien il va de loisirs heures à
wichita mikan tue qui parce que c'est
bien joué
mais j'ai pas mis du gimmick de vie
hyper des comptes leur duo est donc
alors notre ami par ned ski qui me dit
qui nous dit dans le chatt vip league je
ne sais pas ce que c'est
sur le calendrier rapports
cordiaux kentucky par exemple moi je
vois pas comment te qui défend
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils sont trop
rapides l'extérieur et kentucky hyper
lent à l'extérieur donc ils vont
j'espère passer surtout les premiers pas
moi j'ai mis kentucky parce que je sais
pas j'ai l'impression que oscar che bois
il va faire un chantier à chaque match
il va faire sortir les intérieurs
adverses parce qu'ils auront tout cinq
fautes même s'il fera 2 sur 10 aux
lancers francs en fait les zones
d'arrivée
à faire 5 sur 10 hockey
c'est un des ventes de taille pour moi
c'est taye taiwo fait un bon tournoi
un truc hautement scientifique sachez
que chris single tonnes s'est pris
d'amour pour oscar chibout et pour
kentucky cette saison ça veut sans doute
dire qu'ils vont faire l'objet est au
premier tour
par 114 pour rien le simple et hertz des
frères drame et
on sera celle du championnat du monde
c'était une 19 19 en 2010 9019 le mali
tap la france
et les frères dramé qui jouent tous les
deux assez mme petters étaient les deux
meilleurs joueurs probablement
du mal même s'il galère en galère galère
julien je te libère
merci beaucoup pour l' expertise sur
l'ouest tu as qui toi en vainqueur je
t'ai pas demandé que j'ai raison à
situer
on reste sur la côte ouest arizona john
tague à jussiê l'est et
l'ouest
ok les gars merci beaucoup ne vont pas
très bien
rémy sur la dernière
la dernière région midwest qui qui sort
pourquoi de cette région alors tant que
je disposais la région qui est la région
alsace
est bas sur salat moi j'étais je suis
sûr qu'on n'est jamais sûr de tomber sur
deux soit sur la banquette mais celle où
j'ai eu le moindre doute en tout cas
c'est l'âge où je suis o'byrne holtby
away ip qui paie tout
comme ça quand ils seront sortis au
premier tour j'aurais l'air mal à situer
je suis au beurre de relever je suis
amoureux jabbari smith et est arrivé à
une autre formation que je suis le grand
volcker questeur me plaît beaucoup donc
donc voilà je suis au beurre de hold'em
à oui
c'est vrai quoi le coeur kessler est
aussi une assurance pour passer un ou
deux tours en remboursant de compte
contre center un stop qui n'a pas été
fait depuis 2008 en une seule
année 2008 il ya quelqu'un qui l'a fait
ou c'est juste qu'on n'a pas la stature
je sais pas mais j'avais quand j'avais
fait l'article sur voir le coeur
trestler g je trouve personne qui avait
de tels chiffres à la protection de
serre
il a dû il a peut-être baisser un petit
peu parce que les derniers matchs aux
côtés de burn été moins flamboyant
charge mais oui
j'avais smith tulle m à quel point genre
est-ce que tu les robots vas-y au point
d'en faire faire ce pic de draâ ben
voila c'était la question au point d'en
faire un fort pic de drap devant le
hockey mais sert de la vie qui se défend
de plus en plus en ce moment c'est de
plus en plus populaires comme comme
façon de voir les choses est de plus en
plus de gens qu'ils le mettent donc
je vous trouve je le trouve élégant je
le trouve complet je le trouve gros qi
basket
je trouve qu'il a quand même beaucoup de
choses en magasin qui me rassure un peu
plus qu'à brinquin alors je comprends le
fantasme de châteaulin à je le comprends
tout à fait je leur approche tous d'un
banquet euros par exemple mais en terme
de ces projections
ouais ouais ouais moi j'en ferais mais
je suis capable là tout de suite à
l'instant t on attend de voir ce qui va
se passer là pendant quinze jours je
suis capable d'en faire mon numéro de
battre
alors intéressant
alan on n'a pas parlé vous pouvez aller
voir la vidéo sur les stars de la march
madness
vidéo hier avec alan [ __ ]
wololo attend va je vais je vais mettre
un onglet avec lui
mais moussa diabaté que les grains
chantier au rebond offensif
ah oui moussa tout le blaze bayley je
vais vous mettre le playboy plaît à
l'âne
à quel point cette march madness peut
changer
le premier tour de la draft qui arrive
c'est toujours une super bonne question
parce que je sais c'est moi
personnellement ça change quasiment rien
mais moi je suis personne donc et le
truc qui a souvent été créé c'est que
les présidents ou des volets d'un
certain nombre de front office et
n'diaye commence un peu à regarder les
au choix de draft voilà pour la draft à
partir de la march madness parce que
c'est quelque chose de populaire et donc
ça c'est sûr les écrans et des fois on a
qui disent que certains résidants des
opérations basket certains proprios
peuvent pousser pour un joueur qui a été
selon très bon ou a été très mise en
avant par la march madness donc ça peut
bouger des choses pour des joueurs qui
sont qui font qu'ils font rien pendant
l'année qui se révèle un peu à ce moment
là le meilleur exemple pour moi all
times et malaga et richardson et il est
plus en nba d'ailleurs parce que malakal
richardson avant de la march madness je
pense qu'ils présentent même pas la date
parce qu'il fait une saison freshman pas
très bonnes alexis raguse
plus grave au final forme la clef
richardson mais tous ont cependant là il
se retrouve drafté au premier tour et
maintenant ils jouent en israël de
mémoire ou en italie donc ça arrive très
souvent bien être des questions et des
mecs comme dante et di vincenzo des
joueurs comme même jimmer fredette si on
peut voir ceux d'autres knicks tosca se
retrouvent se retrouvent forte dans top
10 pour ça aussi c'est john mitchell
burns dagen mitchell l'an dernier
exactement
ils se retrouvent du christian hart est
aussi potentiellement il faut que tu
peux en fait gagné en côte auprès du
grand public mais ce qu'avait dit aussi
d'autres membres de front office c'est
que souvent pour la laïta draft nba là
les scouts nba de là ils ont terminé
leur leur leur évaluation espace dépasse
plus sur l'europe
non mais c'est pour le grand public ça
peut changer beaucoup de choses
mais trois
sites toujours tous à côté l'ifac
alexandra youtube s'est passé depuis
longtemps plus
tard on a perdu avec ouais on a perdu
son son ca au temple excusez moi pour la
cub ah ouais non c'était juste pour
mettre le score pour faire peur à rémy
50 49 pour michelle krebs houston qui
met des paniers sont pour répondre à une
question que beaucoup y avait une
question sur calais houston ouais je
fais chier
c'est vrai qu'il avait le pedigree de
l'autre hippiques parce que c'est un des
meilleurs joueurs du championnat lycéens
à mondevert et parce que l'on est en
voie ultime canada depuis longtemps mais
en fait il a juste parlé qualités
athlétiques pour être un autre hippiques
mais c'est un très bon joueur c'est
arrivé un très bon tireur il est grand
ce sera un beau rôle player est une
ville mais en fait c'est le problème
c'est qu'on l'avait labellisés comme
notre hippiques et donc comme une voie
puis là maintenant on pense qu'ils
étaient soit mais fallait pas le
labellisé la lottery pick avant il
n'avait jamais vraiment les qualités
athlétiques pour ça reste un très bon
jour et il a il est très bon dans la
deuxième mi temps
hugues
je te laisse enchaîné sur sur caleb
les butins qu'on a et j'ai fait mon
premier big board sais pas j'ai pas
quitter le navire je l'avais encore
garder dans mon top 10 parce que débute
son dramatique où les départs du champ
du terran et tu comprenais pas où il
devait se placer et tout est finalement
maintenant je l'aimais fin du premier
tour comme le dit alan qualités
athlétiques trop trop limitantes
problème d'explosivité c'est pas un
créateur ballaman peu de bons choix aux
quand même si quand il a le ballon il
aime beaucoup passé ligne de fond quand
c'est bloqué par contre comme le
dialogue très très bon tireur capable de
tirer dans trois situations soient à
l'arrêt fin de chaîne en mouvement
pourtant des écrans il a une bonne
rotation au niveau bassin pour pouvoir
se rééquilibrer et armée bien
aujourd'hui qu'ils tiennent pop quelque
chose que il ya peut-être amené à faire
rangement plus grand que son poste de
base et venir poser des écrans pour ses
coéquipiers donc
déçu j'en sais rien parce que je ne suis
pas autant que ce vous le lycée voilà
mai mais un peu frustré forcément
effectivement pas une saison facile du
côté demi finales même si là et
+4
les renverser la tendance les magistrats
scola houston dans toutes les bonnes
saisons il est vraiment sur les femmes
enfin dernier match il était vraiment
très adroit à l'aise ils bougeaient
vraiment mieux donc
voilà quelque chose à faire avec ce
joueur
et il a gobé anneaux
absolument il a que 19 ans et d'ailleurs
si vous faites le split des stats de
caleb du stone
novembre de s'implanter conférence
que je vais essayer de vous montrer tout
à fait immédiatement
lite 21 22
caleb houston ouaki cas c'est normal
aussi pour les freshmen alan de galérer
au début enfin tout le monde n'est pas
déjà barry smith comme rémy ou en parler
concret à l'heure ou chet haine ou paolo
gontero quoi et c'est comme tous les
intérieurs roux qui sont pas et van gogh
l'est c'est pas parce qu'on n'est pas
tout de suite
excellent ou
légitime sur un terrain que c'est que
c'est pas normal mitch et boston l'an
dernier c'était pareil son début d'année
il était horrible aux tirs sur la fin
d'année ça allait mieux le sexe effet
drafté en 55 parce que les gens pourront
vu que le contexte qui ne tue qui je
pense qu'il n'aurait jamais dû tomber si
bas et ils le mangent trouvent être les
clippers cette année que ça c'est un
genre qui aurait pu être qu'ils auraient
dû être achetés plus haut donc ouais
c'est tout le monde n'est pas des tops
freshman plus certains des sont des
situations qui sont pas faciles certains
sont dépendantes de la création des
autres pour scorer comme houston et
c'est vrai que la michigan ils ont perdu
friends wagner ils ont perdu à zahia
leavers qui joue à détroit ils ont perdu
champ de lebron sont perdus plein de
joueurs et donc c'est pas ça même si
voilà il ya un très bon recrutement qui
est fait de jouer à world est un bon
coach moi je reste dans le navire même
si est bon il a une bonne droite aussi
mais à john holmes dans le navire juwan
howard mais voilà c'était le contexte
n'était pas si simple que ça pour pour
lui
absolument et alors que ça lui
[Musique]
une bonne saison on nous demande
beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux
pourquoi on l'a aussi haut alors que
chez ea espiet ni les genres 72e et si
athlétique 346 m je crois ça choquant
palais moquent des autres
parce que déjà parce que je pense que ce
qu'on se seront met en avant ce qui
n'est pas dans le meilleur contexte
possible interdite qui ne sonne est un
super joueur très bon joueur pour le
niveau coller du même plus peut-être
mais c'est pas top comme contexte pour
moussa koussa c'est un genre de fin de
chaîne à l'intérieur il a pas de
meilleur pour lui mettre des ballons et
joue post 4 alors qu'il ya pas vraiment
de tir donc c'est pas vraiment le bon
contexte pour les côtes pense qu'il peut
faire mieux on l'a vu faire mieux
ailleurs ayem j'ai notamment l'équipe de
france u18 c'était le meilleur joueur de
l'équipe pour moi et puis fait c'est
parier sur le fait que dans un autre
contexte un contexte est 9e avec un
développement personnel et avec un
meilleur contexte collectif hip hourra
il pourra fermer parce que le corps et
les capacités athlétiques sont et
l'intensité sont trop trop intéressant
une question de léo qui nous demandent
si jay-z davidson va se présenter à la
draft cette année la plus belle coiffure
de toutes les yeux on a
on a
encore très douce draft qui va sortir
dans après je pense la march madness du
coup peut-être pendant si jay-z davidson
est pas trop fort parce qu'on n'a pas
dit beaucoup de bien de lui alors s'il
est trop fort on va être obligés de
faire le jeu
ne bat pas pour la nba pour l'instant en
fait moi il ya plein de joueurs comme ça
que j'ai dans mon board mais en fait
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'il reste un an de
plus parce que je vois pas comment ils
peuvent être intégrés à une rotation nba
et malgré le fait que la g-league se
développe malgré le fait que ça devient
de plus en plus facile de donner du
temps de jeu à des joueurs dans de
vraies équipes sans les faire jouer
nécessairement en nba donc un peu plombé
la rotation
malgré tout ça ça marche pas tout ça la
plupart du temps les joueurs qui sont
les freshman qui sont graves t1 entre
auto ou deux ans trop tôt ça fonctionne
pas en nba généralement les freshmen
soit tu l'aies drape dans le top 20 se
tuer draft pas quoi vous avez fait à la
barre mois cette année est heureux voilà
on les appelait une fois je serai plus
dire comptes qui mais c'est pour ça que
je suis un peu surpris alors je peux pas
c'est pour ça que je vous écoute parce
que je ne base pas sur un échantillon
d'un match assez c'est ridicule mais le
match on l'a fait je les trouvais très
en contrôle
j'ai vu plein de choses que j'ai aimé
dans ce match là lé sénat en début de
saison je suis plus content qu'ils
seynois taper bronze un gars n'ont ils
ont battu pour un gain en fait non c'est
mais pas quand conz lagarde s'était pas
content vous agace je me souviens plus
mais bref je l'avais trouvée je l'avais
trouvé hyper intéressant mais bon après
sûr il n'est ni neutre ni l'aï testé sur
celle que je préfère regarder jouer
alabama pour sa demande joue super bien
ça joue sajou en tout cas comme comme en
nba en tout cas peut-être le propre de
dieu dit davison c'est que j'ai souvent
parle de la carte d'identité du joueur
pourquoi est-ce qu'on nous draft et lui
ce que tu demanderais de bien faire en
nba n'est pas capable de le faire pour
l'instant parce que c'est un jour de
pitié hollande et davison pour moi c'est
là où il excelle ray le plus et voilà
comment passeur voilà c'est un excellent
passeur sauf qu'il ya un manque de
contre aux il ya manque de qi basket
dans l'est dans les choix ya il ya un
manque de tir ya beaucoup de pertes de
balle et tout est donc ce que tu vas lui
demander de faire oublier pour qu'ils
jouaient haut débit pourra pas le faire
jouer peut-être 2e 3e auteur de bâlois
du ballon du catch and shoot et caetera
et défendre il sera pas en mesure de la
porter
il peut pas jouer et que se passe t-il
ajouté s'il peut jouer il peut jouer
mais si tu veux pas gagner des matches
donc tu peux faire j'ai créé de rafting
comme a fait sont tenues avec primeau et
tu préfère le prendre un en avant comme
ça t'es sûr que l'année d'après il n'est
pas devenu super beau et tu le rates
pasqua mais sauf que alan moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on dise à une peut-être
quinze joueurs c'était noir est
complètement et du coup je pense pas que
ça va marcher avec quinze joueurs
différents et c'est quand même sens on
ne peut nier hausse et un contexte hyper
hyper favorable et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il
ya toujours des contre-exemples surtout
je pense c'est toujours des comptes
raison que les seniors qui grattent des
seniors qui réussissent des voiliers une
tirade des flash mob qui réussissent
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
en fait l'ailé mode draft sont et c'est
pour ça qu'on essaye d'en faire et de
donner un peu notre opinion mais
toujours moi leno board sont plus
intéressants que les mauves grave parce
que les mots grave ça va dépendre des
équipements fatigue aidant équipe où bat
clairement savoure vachement plus le
coup de faire le pari sur tel joueur
d'avenir parce que je sais que mon staff
de développement il est solide que il
aura un super partenaire de pick and
roll en j league et que du coup il va
faire des rêves qui va le faire déraper
et j'ai vu le potentiel et du coup il va
il va bosser arrivé au niveau
suffisant pour avoir un vrai moulin de
billets aulas il ya plein de plein de
choses comme ça c'est tout le temps la
question autour des frais choix entre
guillemets ne déçoivent pas ce que tu as
toujours l'argument de la jeunesse du
potentiel contre l'argument de
l'échantillon d'années ont initié pour
ça qu'il fut souvent c'est bien d'aller
voir ce qu'ils faisaient et school ou
autre chose pour se donner une deuxième
idée mais c'est super dur y'en a plein
chaque année on a plein on les vend on
descend sais pas où les maîtres ont bien
fait reviennent finalement ils n'y vont
pas est-ce qu'on fait donc c'est un bon
débat et léo nous dit que c'était quand
même six heures et demie le match de
l'alabama oui mais
incroyable match durait
exactement que j'avais adoré aussi
évidemment
le problème avec avec les jeunes comme
ça freshman c'est les équipes qu'il
l'ait draft en fait trente et une
équipes entre globalement 23 et 30 thé
des équipes compétitives et celles qui
doivent pas fraîche voilà ce moment là
un jeune potentiel le feront pas jouer
avec une fois elle le draft parce que
c'est du nba touquet et qu' il est de
potentiel et tu te dis bah au pire j'ai
ça dans ma réserve et il flingue délit
flingues des joueurs où aller jaden
springer restée flinguer parce qu'il
peut pas jouer du côté de des
philadelphia
johnson is faisait flingue et parce
qu'il pouvait pas jouer aux côtés
d'équipés et c'est comme ça que tu as
des jeunes talents qui peuvent jamais
finalement se développer et je préfère
d'une équipe le prennent au second tour
mais surtout riz et puissent le faire
jouer plutôt qu'une équipe de fin de
premier tour houthistes sûr que le match
et il en en tant que gérant danemark et
quinting raymi studia way par exemple
par exprès temps plein dès la conclusion
plus des équipes du fin de premier tour
qui veut qu'elle joue le titre et en
pleurs premier tour de draft l'échangent
contre autre chose a san antonio cas de
pic entre 20 et 30 cette année
normalement tu vas voir houston qu'on a
plusieurs ok ici
c'est à les deux sont possibles
est-ce que vous avez des questions dans
le tchat sur le tournoi en ciel parce
que là on a un peu dérivés etc et rémy
est ce que tu as d'autres questions
aussi sur des équipes que tu as tu
aurais pas forcément vu jouer ou est-ce
que tu as d'autres d'autres prévisions
je sais pas quel est cet ami je sais pas
si tu as toujours tombe raquette sous
les yeux je sais pas j'arrive je la sais
pas je me dis que c'est peut-être mais
les cookies ce qui pose problème ce que
j'arrive pas à l'ouvrir un optimum j'en
sais rien mais bref je vous ferais ça
plus tard laisse-moi passé autour de
choses que j'aurais vu et j'ai bien aimé
je suis comme vous thaler l'accord je
sais plus qui me parlait de north
carolina et qui n'y croyaient pas c'est
aussi pour ça que j'étais programmé ce
soir c'est parce qu'à mon avis ça va se
faire sortir
par market et donc c'est l'occasion de
voir dans ce cas on line avant avant que
ça sorte parce que je crois pas en
installer non plus qu'est ce que j'avais
vu d'un peu sympa je voulais j'ai bien
l'équipe ii you et si cette année mais
comme pour moi au second tour ça se
mange o'byrne et bah ça va sortir de là
dessus pourtant c'était une équipe en
laquelle j'avais envie de croire un
petit peu
[Musique]
je sais pas tu disais que c'est une
année ouvert cette année un poisson
ça fait un petit moment j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'a pas eu une année
aussi ouverte aux débuts du march
madness façon
mais il ya plein de fin je ne sais pas
je me souviens plus des obsèques fort
que j'avais mis là dans mon bracket mais
mais mais il ya pas bon à part lui c'est
elle et que je mets champions évidemment
qui est déjà en soi une surprise serait
une surprise mais mais [ __ ] vous aviez
raison alors pour michigan sait plus qui
me dicter une équipe à aubes set et je
faisais le mars étaient
tous là l'homme détester
ils sont gritti quoi ils sont un peu oui
il l'a jamais quoi
écoute voyagerait
faudra pour me pardonner short which
l'homme et là je voyais en plus je
regarde les images là ils font les fous
il ya déjà les draws qui va se prendre
en photo avec la fanfare de la fac et
tous laïcs comme des fous
les rives de la gymnastique sont
démotivés ça gagner le titre encore
elles sont lourdes et voilà comment
comment gagner ils sont faits c'est la
bourse est obligé
d alex suis désolé les gars mais moi il
va fort que je vous abandonne pas
longtemps a dit d'asie m'a dit vas-y
aucun problème mais c'était un régal de
discuter avec vous comme d'hab un
poisson et puis et puis si vous voulez
qu'on rediscute d'ici la fin de la march
madness hésitez pas toi sont donc avec
grand plaisir et bain avec plaisir on
rappelle donc un match par jour sur bin
en vo le soir et en vf le matin avec toi
ou d'autres commentaires mais
principalement avec toi est écrit ce qui
est donc pour kentuky désormais kaki et
fan de ce quartier où est qui et pour
quelle équipe et d'ailleurs c'est pas
est-ce que vous avez suivi juste terme
et dresseur cette anecdote incroyable on
en a parlé dans l'évier on s'est marié
ce que vous savez crise il a la fac il a
joué lui en fac à montana state ouais
moi j'étais en fac à northern colorado
et les deux facs sont dans la même
conférence qui est tout pourri qui est
la big sky conférence est je sais pas si
vous avez vu monter à state a fait une
belle saison ils ont fini premiers de
saison régulière dans le colorado avait
fini 3e mais ils ont sorti le deuxième
don qu'il se retrouve en finale de conf
alors en finale de conf n'y a pas eu de
match pour thalassa est à gagner ok mais
sur le dernier jour de la saison
régulière les deux équipes s'affronter
est-ce que vous avez vu ce que ça va
donner
un ambiance j'ai près n'est pas juste
moi c'est incroyable je me suis levé le
matin j'ai cru que j'allais avalé de
travers c'est est numéro 1 du top ten
sports center je vous raconte pas ce
qu'il faut pour être numéro 1 du top ten
sportscenter quand vous êtes montana
state et d'argent colorado plus de 90
colorado balle de match enfin pas libre
pendant votre colorado à 4,6 secondes
c'est plus de la fin plus de remise en
jeu montana state lemaitre shoot du logo
de dents au buzzer victoire de montana
c'est incroyable ça n'assomme voilà
seulement intersidéral et donc sachez
que single tonnes va suivre montana
state je sais même plus compte qu'ils
jouent au foyer tour et je leur souhaite
d'en prendre 60 bus sur la gueule texas
tech 7 chez moi the order lors dun
colorado ils ont un vrai joueur norden
colorado il va jouer en europe je pense
des classiques ou non il était à
colorado avant et je les ai vus parce
qu'ils ont joué contre arizona cette
année un petit gaucher très fort je vois
les berges gaubert
bah montana state toi et au texas tech
qui peuvent s'en prendre
et ben parfait comme ça j'en verrai des
sextos aussi bien comme je dirais chef
rémi merci d'être passé merci beaucoup
avec plaisir les gars c'est un plaisir
comme d'hab à bientôt c'est mon goût à
bientôt votre charge
hugues je vais faire une petite pause de
mon côté j'ai des obligations mais je
reviens tout de suite après je vous
laisse le lead je vous laisse discuter
de ce michigan colle au colorado state
croire et puis et puis on arrive tout de
suite après
je ne vais pas demain switch envergure
et bien sûr voilà tu vois le chef picard
ont fait notre pub on glisse
dessus c'est bien mais venus surtout si
on fait ça demain
21h21 30 comme d'hab et nombreux joueurs
un à miser y est ça y est on va faire on
a annoncé vendredi dernier la monsieur
les conneries je t'enlève l'un du mardi
qui gagnent murray et deux joueurs nba
et ça va être salé spoile pas ça va être
juste turbo non
on va kiffer on va être fait on aura
sûrement seront pleins de trucs à dire
sur le sur les résultats de maarten
laisse
toi je ne sais pas on observe habite à
d'autres équipes ou pas pur produit
alors haïti j'ai mis des villes saintes
qui sort michigan state ok ok donc parce
que vos goûts juwi qui prend feu qui
naissent et foster loyère qui récuse un
qui rejoue contre les sportsman il était
schengen state il les a quittés cette
année lire complètement en feu et nous
je vois bien foster loyaux qui assassine
son ancienne équipe mais je t'ai confie
de tamise ou alors
rischmann qui t'a pas y aura
je suis pas extrêmement confiant parce
que l'iowa est sur une très bonne
dynamique on va pas se mentir le tournoi
de big ten alors c'est une très bonne
dynamique mais je trouve que ce serait
être big ten en termes de haut niveau du
jeu c'était pas vraiment exceptionnel
ils vont au bout parce que ils vont vous
mais c'était pas incroyable
ensuite par marc et jamie market que
north carolina c'est un objet de luxe et
un infime 1,8 mais c'est pas vraiment un
adepte être incroyable non plus avec un
très gros lewis
john lewis
est ce que j'ai mis sept sauber jimmy
north carolina quand même j'ai mis j'ai
mis hou annecy
mais ils sont une vraie qui marque comme
ouais j'ai mis côte comme eux peut-être
virginia tech qui bat texas
j'ai mis
ce n'est pas mis énormément d'autres
jetés en somme
moi de mon côté ce que j'ai fait ce que
j'ai fait j'ai hésité à mettre iowa
state compter là dessus et les cieux son
coach et que ça finit mal aimés iowa
state a très mal commencé la saison et
deux pick up avec moi c'est pas
incroyable non bah ils ont ils ont
apprécié limites en tant de beaux
talents variés voit sa tête aussi ils
ont un excellent coach à qui arrivait
donc là ils ont un très très bon meneur
avec tyson qui va prendre la relève que
je sais que tu aime beaucoup
mais quand même l essieu sais c'est
l'audi laissé beaucoup trop physique je
pense pour frei au west ait pu y avoir
un vrai match moi j'ai mis manami
kisorio aussi par exemple ok je les aime
en outils sont vieux ils sont anciens
ils connaissent la route c'est ça et
wang va sauter par dessus tous leurs
joueurs c'est à
seddouk peterson je crois l'ailier des
lois si wes anderson va manger les
testicules de wayne donc on va parier
là-dessus et puis est ce que j'en ai
d'autres est ce que j'en ai d'autres
tout je vais j'y vais comme san
francisco contre me restait avant de
savoir pour la blessure j'ai aussi vu
j'ai aussi mis vtec qui bat texas et
après j'ai hésité cette mairie indiana
mais comme j'aime pas trés succintes
davis je vais parler jours sur sept mais
moi
je pas le plus grand fan non plus de
treize activistes qui progresse pour le
dire ils ont sorti rüttgers du coup
c'est ça c'était ça la même nom indiana
a tapé wyoming et voyage l'attendait
matin perd 2,15 ok donc on verra par un
art hors du nord cette année en mars en
baisse quel dommage
quel dommage on verra votre gobelet
quitely la cuisse leigh day wood green
est la super ex
internés bien qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
on aille à memphis memphis beau exister
et qui a commencé
walfisz challenger n bien sûr
j'ai entendu brega vrai qu'à drafté en
fin de premier tour
landers noël ancien joueur ancien
shooteur de virginia tech qui va
transférer qui aurait moins de carrière
je pense chez les pros contre bozzi
state c'est une fan de justin yanji
simple c'est une fable est championne
kingson qui avait douze derniers
devraient faire un
nom au premier tour mais jobs s'est fait
arrêter par les warriors deuxième tour
bref un deuxième pic depuis le seul
à vous qui cab est un prospect of the
state l'ancien champion du monde u 19
avec team canada où vous avez tapé les
américains dans une équipe est chargée
barrette loup dorthe chais qui est dans
cette équipe aussi
et qui gap qui a fait 2 en oregon et
maintenant est abolie state poésie
stakes et dans l'idaho ont déjà on sait
pas trop c'est dans l'idaho donc c'est
un peu c'est au-dessus du du colorado il
ya ces départs naturels et des chevaux
sauvages d'hébron cause de bugs et ça
c'est ça c'est une équipe souvent très
bien coachée qu'ils ont bien ils peuvent
vraiment embêté memphis 1 ils ont
beaucoup moins de talent bien entendu de
talent nba plus plus mais ils peuvent
ils peuvent embêter san diego south
dakota state qui à moins 8 une
médecin confidences et la pro vie des
petits lapins toi qui gère la big east
providence avec le coach elle coulait
qui fait jouer quarante minutes tous
égards l'objectif c'est de tom thibodeau
delane si est franchement c'est un truc
de l'année dernière et vite dookie jouer
38 minutes par match car on est aussi
bail à brooklyn m'attendais milieu
agricole c'est ça
on a aussi b alors qu'a commencé contre
norfolk state est ce que tu peux me
citer le joueur nba qui a été drafté et
qui joue à norfolk state ce que tous
n'ont pas eu beaucoup aidé au queen est
oui alors il nous faut voir alex les
pour ça que c'est le chef j'étais
d'ailleurs exactement la recette pour
faire des obsèques d'henri paul state il
avait fait un bon run il me semble à
l'époque il rumine un jeu complètement
donc voilà je gagnerai un + 8 il reste
trois minutes trente sept jours pour
colorado state cela va être dur il va
falloir que c'est le moment de david
rodier je crois waouh d'asia stevens
info que ça que ça met dedans et ensuite
on aura longwood contre tennessee alors
tennessee moi je les attends parce que
cette année au tout le monde dit c'est
la bonne ils vont pas se faire obsède ça
va bien se passer
on attend rick barnes à la march madness
et ensuite il y aura quoi d'autre
richemont daiwa georgia states tags à la
georgia state de hergé hunter et de son
père qui s'était cassé la jambe puis
ensuite qu'elle est tombée sur le buzzer
de hergé hunter contre baylor images
incroyables
amènera choix d'offres par les celtics
on oublie pas
absolument et vous avez quoi d'autre
comme obsède vous au premier tour la
lega a
on a fait la petite juste avant ce
discours à vous avez fait la livre on a
mis tous ceux qui bossent
jerry chenkin baïona à wissam el richman
pas
vous montrer mon deuxième bracket pour
vous faire voir quand même comme c'est
un peu rigolo gmi sauce dakota state du
coup qui lui donne ce même s'il a moins
8 et que c'est mal barré je voulais
fight for gonzaga ucla villanova wyss
consignes
mais maintenant je voulais je voulais m
creighton qui bat santé ghost rythme et
j'ai été interdit
familièrement
pas été trop pour moi c'est oui
complètement il a fait son bracket avec
soin dgos et de 20h des
impôts ce qui est impossible à réaliser
mais creighton peut taper son négoce a
été ça serait un obstacle puisque c'est
un 9 8
mois créée par craig ruttle
huit cadavres richmond pour moi cette
manne derrière celle d'un autre ah oui
je te dis des conneries ces réactions
vous adore arthur kaloum à arthur kaloum
à
alex o'connell l'ancien de duke viennent
selon
brian et marne le petit frère d'andrew
andrew état dans un garage un état état
ils ont quoi ils sont vraiment construit
pour faire un bon truc adana j'adorais
leur équipe déjà avec marcus égard aux
skis et tout ça demi-frère
exactement l'ifrad avec un carton -
match que ces coachs mcdermott qui a eu
des propos benoît d'arc à la con
traversable wild a comparé ses joueurs
une
tribu des slaves en gros le moment ce
qui a fait que ty télé washington qui
devait jouer là-bas à des comités partie
ce que tu as kentucky ce qui a revu à ce
qu'il me dit bouleversé tous les plans
de coach calipari qui avait déjà
récupéré sa vieille wheeler de georgia
may west ham s'est toujours très bien
coacher franchement
la cote comme vous est possible parce
que san francisco san francisco va me
rester ça sera un obsède bon je les ai
mis jeu est amusant petit trou que j'ai
pas j'ai pas la peau de la blessure la
blessure de leur intérieur c'est une
très bonne équipe en c
une bonne conférence jouent bien ils ont
deux gardes qu'on est très bonne qui
vont jouer en europe ils ont un
transfert de boston collège sur le banc
riche wayne qui est très bon aussi c'est
vraiment une bonne équipe san francisco
l'ancienne femme de bill russell
d'ailleurs c'est le seul joueur qui on
est vraiment sorti et j'avais très bien
commencé la saison est à présent un peu
plus de galère sans peu plus loin dans
le rang
mais ils sont sortis d'une conférence
qui est très souvent
dominé par
à travers la paroi gahé piederrière
punchline mais cette année mais pas des
newell's
regretterait mois or de se voir du coup
les amis
les amis avant qu'on se quitte
est ce que on peut donner des conseils
de visionnage au moins pour ces deux
premier round donc là on a dit boyle
state même fils ça peut être pas mal
ouais
iowa richman
reichmann se mirent à 3h10
américaine donc mr leur dise
ce qu'il y a que cinq heures en ce
moment du changement d'heure et de
uconn new mexico state peut-être donc
north carolina market sur 102 cost est
très bonne pour moi c'est pour moi c'est
bien sans diego state crétois san diego
state creighton et en même temps quasi
saidov match c'est maryse indiana
et après évidemment n'hésitez pas garder
en fait toujours un oeil sur les scores
en cours parce que ça
peut clairement ça peut clairement
bouger imaginez centers qui accroche
kentuky cinq dernières minutes au
plateau ward direct faut aller voir
direct parce qu'il se passe toujours des
trucs il y aura forcément un buzzer
beater ou quasi par jour au moins ceux
pour ces quatre jours qui arrivent et
pour demain vos matchs préféré messieurs
je vous mets la liste aussi
de mon
eau à you stay de la chicago ça c'est
bien déjà pour commencer la journée
c'est sympa
by me donne encore plus incroyable notre
dame à plat bama ça va être peut-être
l'équipe le match plus sexy au niveau
offensif de
2,7 cette première first round du first
rand des
mois je possède le mode de vie
continue colgate attention à colgate
face et ce comme si j'avais le dire et
au niveau des français on aura sept
halls
alexis y est tu n'as contre
attaque aussi montana street avec les
deux français ouais nadège macho et
ouais exactement texas tech au s2 de
français ça va être intéressant aussi
en doute les français qui vont aller le
plus loin dans
la campagne
voilà messieurs je veux je vais clore ce
live puisque j'ai des obligations
professionnelles et de toute façon on
l'a dit l'essentiel on a donné nos bras
kate et puis vous pouvez aller voir nos
deux vidéos donc comment ça fonctionne
avec médaille tant campos et lessard de
n'diaye et puis et puis demain il ya un
string messieurs ou quoi sur la danse
est d'ailleurs annoncée aussi préparer
notre pub sur notre lancée vous êtes
vraiment profite quand le chat n'est pas
là
merci à ceux qui nous ont suivis merci
au chat bon bah je crois que michigan
c'est cuit coque ou quoi ouais ça va
passer
mais michigan qui passe face à colorado
state c'est beau de la part d'un voyage
je te pouvoir émigrer grosse deuxième mi
temps
ces 16 sur la deuxième mi temps ouais
vous pouvez envoyer des messages à
réunion
on le remercie d'être passé et on vous
fait des bisous à tous ciao ciao ciao